Hodel which seen in your latest film the
assassin are you most proud of and why
one partner you can think of that like
this the part where her father has
already been injured so they're just
hiding out like in the village and the
farmhouse and she was brewing medicine
for her dad
that's seeing and then she stops going
to started saying that you know she is
very lonely she's the only person of her
kind there's no one else like her and
then she even just got quite emotional
as she's delivering that line I think
that whole sequence I like quite a bit
in American cinema there is a phrase
we'll fix it in post what are your
thoughts on editing and that phrase for
me I definitely agree with that
statement
because for me if something is not
working I just cut it out
I cut out whatever is that I don't like
and some people worry about continuity
but I feel like there's actually always
a way out
in terms of continuity you will figure
something out that was still somehow
make the movie make sense so I am a
strong believer in editing I've read
that you've said your films are much
more popular in Japan or Europe why not
in your homeland yeah I think it's
difficult because in Taiwan most people
still watch Hollywood movies other
movies are very popular in Taiwan and
obviously Holly Holly movies they tend
to be more dramatic there's a lot going
on it's very heightened so for this
generation of moviegoers and spectators
in Taiwan that's the kind of movies they
like and this movie it took me several
years to make it so now I feel like I'm
actually dealing with even a newer
generation of audience whose taste is
even harder for me to grasp and who have
even
a set of aesthetics and taste that's
even further removed from the previous
generations so this is a unique
challenge for me and it's something that
I'm trying to figure out because I feel
like my movies could be quite difficult
for people for these audiences
how does he feel that the new
generations tastes have changed is very
interesting because I think the internet
actually has changed a lot of things
because I think this new generation
they're viewing habit is different
because they view a lot of stuff on
their device so the way people come soon
media custom film is actually
fundamentally different from before now
I think people generally tend to be less
patient because you know they have they
can very easily choose whatever they
want and they can skip and stop and go
somewhere else
you have to watch something whereas a
movie especially going to a theater and
being a spectator with an audience that
requires a certain amount of
participation patience even but with
this generation of young people who just
watch movies and we didn't consume
content on official devices I feel like
their public last patient they can watch
the entire movie and come some come to
writing the subway and watching stuff on
their cell phone so I feel like that's
one way in which the viewing habits
fundamentally changed and that's
creating new aesthetics and new
perception as well hold out of your
career of your numerous movies you've
had a documentary made about you you've
had books written people theorize about
your filmmaking
we've been at con so many times what has
been the most greatest reward from the
whole journey of all of that yeah for me
actually simply been about just choosing
what's hot the movie itself issues need
to be a filmmaker and that self has been
filled with joy that has been rewarding
because you could say that through a lot
of things I wanted to make movies an
early age and I did end up making movies
and I feel like I did reach the certain
level but obviously when it comes to
artistic and creation there any kind of
artistic expression I feel like there
shouldn't be an end this shouldn't be
like a limit to it it's important for
one to keep exploring keeping forth and
moving further down so for me even
though I'm 68 right now I'm almost 70
actually
quite old but I feel like I still have
the same energy the same motivation and
I just want to keep pushing the boundary
keep moving forward and explore the
medium of cinema even further so for
example we were talking about digital
communication and the digitization of
cinema for me I actually want to explore
that for my next film I want to shoot on
digital camera and just to experience
just to experiment with that so I'm
someone who just wants to keep pushing
forward they just keep those paths I
believe in a documentary about you
hoedown it was done when you're around
50 you your grandmother had gone to a
fortune teller and the fortune teller
said oh he is going to be a very
powerful man how much do you attribute
your career to luck and good fortune and
how much hard work and attention to
detail hmm movies are very detailed and
very beautiful subtle little things in
them that really stand out how much of
that is detail and how much is luck yeah
because what happened originally was I
was born in China and as at I was
popular to go to for $10 so what the
fortune teller exactly said at the time
is one day I would be coming important
official this is really being an
official within the government that's
what the fortune teller meant don't
become a major important official so I
thought why I thought about this before
it's like I didn't really exactly become
an official but I thought to myself
maybe becoming a director that's real
like it's government official in the
sense that I get to come show people I
get to manage and supervise certain
things but just talking about my family
in Korea itself I think I just want to
emphasize the fact that movie has been
the only worthwhile for me it's about
human beings it's dealing with the human
characters the human beings have found
the kerosene and I feel like humans are
fascinating they're wonderful they're
interesting they're moving they're
compelling just humanity itself is so
beautiful and compelling and I'm someone
who fundamentally believes in decency
and the compassion and the goodness of
people
so to want to continue to focus on human
beings to make them the subject of my
film that itself is an expression an act
of faith in the sense that I have faith
that human beings are fundamentally
good that no matter what happens even
though there's been a lot of policies
and prediction about how humanity you
know we're losing our basic decency
we're becoming worse and worse but I do
believe that at the end of the day we
are have that capacity for good for
compassion for beauty and that self is
very moving to me
to be able to capture that to be able to
make movies focusing on that that itself
has been so worthwhile the movies are
very moving for me cuz even to this day
I would watch movies in the theater on
television oftentimes I get profoundly
moved but the stuff I see because the
expression it's the hardest perception
and perspectives in the world is an
extension for me to be able to behold
that to be able to watch that itself is
moving so movies are really a source of
great beauty and paralysis or discomfort
unit Thank You Sasha thank you